maybe now live from their homes in leads
straight into yours we have property
agents Agee retired couple Liz and Phil
stay home on a six a deef and also with
us Claire a retired teacher hello
everyone how are we doing we were
talking about this time last week won't
we about life or lockdown where you are
talking Maya zoom everyone at home now
be familiar with this because they check
their friends and family in exactly the
same way most days and there's a few pop
quizzes going on as well I know and if I
could just ask you to put yourselves on
mute well I just talk and then when I
ask you a question if you can unmute
yourself you want to talk to each other
which I know you've been doing over the
last few weeks so just unmute yourself
to be heard and sitting if I'm going to
come to you first because you are where
this all began with a letter you popped
through - everybody's letterbox - get
everyone together and what's that group
came from that and since we spoke seven
days ago that whatsapp group has swelled
in number joined in our group now so
we've got a total of 40 helpful from the
street during the walk that room and
he's absolutely fantastic the group is
very active every day we've got people
messaging we've got you know we keep up
to date with each other check in with
each other and it's really really have
you know given such a boost to the
morale on the street spirits are really
high now because of the group I think
it's a fantastic group and a lovely
mixture of people as well amazing yeah
well what are the kinds of people have
joined your ranks obviously you're a
mother of six we've got Fatih the
businessman got retired teacher listen
Phil you know there's so many different
kinds of households in the street who
who has been added to the mix what are
they like so we've got actually a lot of
our key workers are joined in now as
well which is amazing because you know
we find you know what they're doing from
the front line as well and we thought
you know people joining now we've got a
few teenagers of a job board joined into
the group as well so if the lovely
mixture of Ages it's the lovely mixture
of you know people doing different
things we've got older people younger
people it's just
fantastic bunch of people yeah you're
really building a community while you're
in lockdown and fatty again last time we
spoke it was again the eve of well the
eve before clap for carers I know you
were heading out as a street as you do
every Thursday daddy it is also the
start of Ramadan as well so you were
signaling the start of that how's that
been for the last week
well since last week lockdown has been
quite challenging it is quite hard to
stay at home and fast for over 18 hours
normally I would socialize with friends
but unfortunately acara Duda and that
has raised a lot of anxiety for me
however the group has been absolutely
amazing whenever I feel anxious or
depressed I just text a group and they
come up with such positive vibe and that
keeps me motivated ongoing and also it
must be a time of just like meeting a
lot of more books and it's little more
spiritual and getting more close it's my
faith and that's what Ramadan is all
about these are all prophets teachings
and is a smart about staying humble
staying together appreciate everything
you have love in your neighbours showing
love and compassion and it's like a
blessing for me because whenever I open
the glorious quran all them basic
teachings are just what we're doing
today so it is something overwhelming
for me and it just keeps me positive and
going yeah you know so interesting that
you're finding a different sites or
Ramadan because obviously you celebrate
a market differently I love that okay
I'm gonna come to you and have you been
doing for the last week and we've all
noticed a change in the weather where I
am in London is pretty great miserable
and that can make a difference cause its
life a lockdown what's even like a
Belize
well I mean the way there hasn't been
that great but I think like [ __ ] says
it's been quite a challenging week and
as it goes on you can get well I can get
quite anxious abut and fearful and I've
found that like the energy for a media
reports this can be one of high anxiety
this is easy to be seduced by that you
become part of that fear and the more
negative emotion there is the more it
hooks people in and it kind of takes
over your mind so I find what is helpful
is to
be as present in the moment as you can
and one way for me to do this is by
crafting so this week I've spent quite a
lot of time just wet felting which is
what's that you use sheep's wool to
build up pictures or objects and then
you you felt it with warm water soap and
a lot of agitation with it removing it
about a bitten go creates pictures and
stuff like that so it's very it can help
you be really mindful okay I'm looking
forward to seeing some of the finished
results maybe next week you can unveil
them how are you getting on because Phil
I know when we spoke last week and you
can send about your mom Phil who is in
the vulnerable category and you can get
to see her and there's some concerns
about hospital visits as well I think
what has changed there we speak to
everyday this had to go to the hospital
for a scans which was worrying for both
of us both because the scan might show
something but also just sort of her
going into a hospital at the moment for
an hour or two when obviously it's a big
source of infection whether that's a we
seem to survive and we're just waiting
for the results I didn't want him to
come with me originally but I was I
don't think I was fit to drive so I got
him to take me there and then leave me
at the door and I went even did my
appointments on my own using it when you
have to go into hospital at the moment
you're not allowed to take anyone with
you I feel for you I've been through
exactly the same experience in the last
couple of weeks I don't know about you I
noticed is not only our NHS staff at the
moment providing excellent medical care
no stepping up their emotional support
and I was overwhelmed by the kindness
and the man stepped up their game
because they're in PPE you can't see
their faces it's very impersonal
and you're going in there you know
worried and alone is that the experience
you have because I found it strangely
reassuring very much so it was from
I entered the hospital and salt went to
the reception they were really Pleasant
you know sort of processing very quickly
but with a human touch and then when I
got to having my examination they she
was a lovely
it was super well about a super is it
cabbage I understand what you mean I
understand exactly what you mean Liz oh
it's good that he had failed to come out
there too new to supporting each other
and we've got my fingers crossed for you
and the results of those that scam and
just in terms of you know the clap for
carers obviously as a couple that much
must take on particular residents for
you in light of that obviously Phil
talking about thinking about your mom
Liz thinking about your own health and
finding out that now you've got key
workers on your street you've got people
on your road who are going in every day
to work on the frontline yeah major
banner with all the names of people on
the street very grateful everybody's
putting their lives at risk so just
these have a tumble and she's doing a
run at the weekend a couple of police
officers there who came and picked her
up and dusted off and salty they're out
it really makes you realize how
important all these people are three
lives just taken for granted in normal
life yeah but they're making a huge
difference yeah these people on the
front line and our neighbors as well so
these how are you getting on with
homeschooling because I know you're a
mom of six and my stepson is staying
with us this week it's been interesting
tips you've got six kids to juggle how
do you do know obviously this week for
me I think you know the first few weeks
I think I'm just completely given up I
mean the children all the fun
for checking in with us every other day
absolutely amazing and in my opinion now
I respect you teach us so much before
but now I have major major respect and
love for all those teachers outlined
because I am really struggling I'll be
honest if you start managing the home
managing cleaning you know cooking and
then I go out a lot to a lot of work
within the community as well so for me
it you know trying to home-school five
children as well I have just people of
love / honesty I love your eyes I think
the situation that we are all in now is
something nobody could have ever
predicted off take each day as it comes
and just enjoy that time as a family
don't put yourself through extra stress
yes it is that's such good advice is
okay not for it for everything not to be
okay junior global pandemic
and there has been a bit of good news
today actually cope with us you because
you were talking about obviously the
news making you quite anxious at the
moment it's really important to get a
balanced news diet and look for the good
news as well as the bad news which is
just you know sadly part and parcel of
what we're going through and the Prime
Minister today and his fiance having a
baby boy I mean she find that cause Rob
some ism is that a boost for the
nation's morale yeah I guess it is yeah
I think any news of any but any new
births it's really really happy and
positive yeah it's nice to have
something positive on the news for once
yeah I think every every news program
should start off with five minutes of
positivity and then you know you can
decide if you want to switch off after
that or not believe me we are looking
for it clear here at Sky News we really
are in fact it's good gives me to plug
my new podcast in this together it is
Chalker with positive good news Claire
we've got it on the Sky News platform
all over the place but it is in one
place for you to listen to and Fatih
just finally for you obviously Ramadan
continues and you were saying that you
were finding and new positives from that
and from your whole experience what are
your plans for the for the week ahead to
keep your mind right in lockdown and
keep going well
making these little logs out do it so
I'm getting the positive feedback see
jolly body and keeping it with smile and
that's the ethics of envelope with and
for me eight sometimes you know how you
gather emotional twenty over 20,000
people passing away and you know you're
not wooden stick I even see the game
buried is this you know it's question
you know we need to question ourselves
you know you know what we do it in life
and what's the sum of my life and just
cherish every moment I mean I had well
five holidays booked this year
potentially they're all going to get
canceled so and what I'm looking forward
for now is once the flights open I'm
gonna fly out for a long time and I'm
gonna do a lot of charity work and go
around you know to like the third world
countries and see how they are like as
well because you know it's an eye-opener
really and believe me I'm gonna go for a
long time and love every moment of it
life is too short so does that suits me